hi everyone i'm huma abedin and i have
worked for hillary clinton uh for the
last 25 years i know that's a long time
a quarter of a century and one of the
things i'm gonna do today is
read some quotes by powerful women
there's a mix in this bowl i'm told of
quotes by hillary
and by another very powerful woman
leslie knope from parks and rec let's
see if i can figure out who's who
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to be direct and honest with
you i would like a glass of red wine and
i'll take the cheapest one you have
because i can't tell the difference okay
that is definitely leslie knope that is
not hillary clinton also i don't really
see her drinking a lot of red wine and
hillary's more of a martini
yeah or white wine or like chardonnay
ding ding ding maybe it's time for more
women to be in charge i want to say
that's leslie knope
so far leslie's doing pretty well here
zuma
next time just knock louder well that is
a quote from my book both and to life in
many worlds which is on sale at the
moment and so that i know is a hillary
clinton quote
i guess some people object to powerful
depictions of awesome ladies now while
this applies to both women i believe
leslie knope said this
excellent this is a tough one people i'm
undaunted in my quest to amuse myself by
constantly changing my hair i can't
really imagine hillary saying this
publicly so
while it is true
i'm gonna say it's leslie knope is that
correct it's hillary oh my god
all right i should have okay well it
could have gone either way winning is
every girl's dream
leslie nope
yeah can't see hillary saying that but
it's a good quote all of these apply to
both of them actually
in my white house we will know who wears
the pantsuits
that's hillary
and i think i remember when she said
that i wish i had some stock in a
scrunchie company unfortunately although
i do wear scrunchies like all the time
like every night in bed i wear a
scrunchie so i don't mean to be
dismissive of scrunchie hillary clinton
said that because she does love her
scrunchies as do i what i hear when i'm
being yelled at is people caring really
loudly at me
leslie has to be leslie go find your
team get to work whatever that work is
that you find worth doing
do it and find some people to love
who'll do it with you that's hilary
that's lightning holy can i take this
one because we should use this in her
next speech thank you leslie we're
stealing those we're going to put in the
next hillary video slash speech there is
a sense that things if you keep positive
and optimistic about what can be done do
work out okay i definitely did not write
that did hillary say this not really
well done hillary
yes
that quote we can forget americans need
a champion and i want to be that
champion thank you hillary
and now for the final last one in our
little white bowl i know this is going
to be a trick one take a chance don't be
afraid of what you don't know and don't
fall in love with plan a this is my mom
this is my mom's quote this is not
leslie or hillary this is my mom's quote
from my book and i got it right
drew thank you for having me i had so
much fun today and i hope you'll have me
back and i hope people go out and buy my
book both and a life in many worlds that
was amazing thanks for asking me to do
it it was great i am taking this one
you